hello everybody markiplier here and I
wanted to take some time to actually
talk with you guys because I don't do
these V logs enough and I don't share
enough with you guys so that you know
what's going on in my life because this
channel is very important to me and you
guys are so important to me because
you've been supporting me so strongly
throughout this time that I can't forget
that I can't forget this connection that
I made with you guys and and I never
want to I never want to lose sight of
what we've have just because we passed
half a million subscribers doesn't mean
that I care less for each subscriber
that joins us and we're getting over
3,000 a day like sometimes up to 7,000
8,000 I can't even keep track of it
anymore and it's all thanks to you guys
you're like seriously from the bottom on
my heart I'm so eternally grateful that
you guys support me so much it's
actually quite warm out here I'm
sweating if you can't tell sorry I'm a
little bit disgusting for this V log but
I sincerely want to thank you guys for
everything that you've done for the
channel and keep it up because we are
doing an amazing thing and most
importantly I have not forgotten about
the charity livestream this month I've
just been incredibly busy with going
down to South Carolina and health and
cyndago and stuff like that but here's
the thing my birthday is this Friday
June 28th I was born at bouncing
muscular babies so awesome you guys know
the story you've seen my draw my life
video but I want to celebrate it in a
very special way and I want to do my
charity livestream on my birthday so if
you guys will join me on Friday for my
birthday we're gonna play a bunch of
games I'm gonna try to get Bob and Wade
involved as much as I can if they're
gonna join me if they're not that's fine
I'll carry on on my own we'll play some
games we'll get some different stunts
that I'll pull for every donation we get
or every thousand dollars we get we're
gonna raise $25,000 for child's play
that's right
$25,000 and if you don't know about
child's play check the description I'll
provide a link for the website in short
they provide entertainment for kids who
are stuck in hospitals for long periods
of time for childhood cancer they
provide game gaming systems and TVs so
that they can have their friends come in
and visit them they can
fun together because some of these kids
are stuck in there for years years of
their life just wasted away in the
hospital hopefully this little bit of
joy that they can bring in will help
them get through their the illness and
hopefully they'll get better so
sincerely thank you guys for joining me
hope you're there for my birthday I want
to hit the goal I want to hit it hard
and I would rather I would rather see
money go towards charity than any
present towards me like I I stopped
caring about getting presents a long
time ago and I really hope that you
understand that I would love I would
nothing would make me happier than
reaching this goal on my birthday so
thank you guys so much for watching and
if I had one wish I guess if I'm going
to be selfish for a little bit it said I
asked you guys to just keep doing what
you're already doing like take take the
time out of your day take my favorite
your favorite video mind that you've
ever seen it could be a compilation or
anything or one of the small indie games
I've done and show it to a friend like
telling them about the channel get one
more subscriber going like if everyone
who watches this Disqus one more
subscriber going that would make me
really happy if you really want to give
me something just help the channel grow
because the more people we have in the
channel the more we can do for charity
the more we can do for helping the world
out and so sincerely thank you guys so
much for all your support its unending
it's unreal I can't even begin to thank
you guys enough for it so thank you and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye